みなさんこんにちは高橋真麻役って言います
早速ですけど
をバーン元禄演奏花離宮
これってなの名前かわかりますか
続いては
アスペン白樺トドマツだったけ
桧杉これ何に使われる
気でしょ
正解はですね
割り箸でございます
小判元禄店そげ離宮これは割り箸の形です
0さっきのアスペンから薄着にかけてあれも後ろに行けば行くほど運と高級とされてい
ます
これです
僕が持っているこれ俺9寸すぎ柾目離宮走っています
箸袋名詞になってるんですけど
えっ
えーこれはですねあのあって使ういわゆる
割はしですね割り箸の中では最高級と言われています
実はですね僕の会社ではこの割り箸をつくっております
この割り箸で皆さんカップラーメンとか食べたことってありますか
あの必聴に美味しく感じるんですよ
ほんと不思議なんですけど
何でしょ
本当500円とか600円とそんなラーメンくってるよ
気になるんですよね
あのスーパーとかであの見かけたらもぜひあの
騙されたと思って試してみてください
でまぁもしって言ったのはですねあの実は
あの国内のね国内で出回ってる割り箸っていうのは95%以上
外国産なんですよ
国産というのはも5%ありません
でまぁ僕の会社のこの割り箸
高級割り箸なんで
もその5%の中のごくごく一部2%いいかですよね
っていうわけでスーパーではこの割り箸
買えないんでしただめです
はぁ
どうしても欲しいっていう案の方いらっしゃったらあの僕の会社に連絡してください
あの売るほどあります
ですねあんまり知られてないんですけど割り箸の歴史ってね
300年以上あるといわれています
で奈良県の吉野時報が圧勝ののれっきとした日本ので伝統産業なんですよね
でこの利休箸この日9場所もですねあの原型は千利休が作ったから
rikyu 利休箸って言われるようになったと言われています
でじゃあねなんで
国産のあり橋がそんだけ視野が落ちちゃったのかと
どうしちゃったんだと
これ答えは簡単なんですけど
値段ですよ
あの日本にしかなかった割り箸
うんと最初台湾
韓国インドネシア
アメリカそこら辺で作られ初めてですね
で
えーと今ではほとんど中国一国で生産されて輸入されています
まあほんと1円でも安く買いたいとかねどんどん安く買いたい
どうしても安く買いたいっ
そう言うと結果ですよ
でどうしてこうなっちゃったのかといいますと
結局日本人があのその国々機械持ち込んだんですよ
もともとその国ではどうあり橋使われる週間てなかったわけですから
日本発祥の日本しかなかったものなので
結局日本人が
持って仕事ほんとひどい話なんですけどね
で
そんなねあの中国産の割り箸がもう出回るようになってから
20年以上経ってます
1膳これに比べると思う本当びっくりするような値段なんですけど
越前市いいか
でも安かろう悪かろう
うまく割れないとかね押忍豪れちゃうとか
そんな割り箸がですね
20年以上で回り続けちゃってるとどうなります
あの
ほんと日本発祥だったはずのね300年以上歴史があるっていう割り箸が誰かが誰かが
割り箸というイメージに変わっちゃいません
ほんとどうでもいいなんて言うかただ同然のね
木の棒みたいになっちゃってませんか
もうあのはせです忘れられそうになってるんですけど
あのちょっと前ですけどめっちゃ入りましたがおもてなし
あの
大切なねお客様をもてなすために
もうぞ真心を込めたね美味しい料理に添えられるのって
古来ね本来は高貴な割り箸だったんですよ
あのはられてなかったら誰にもすっはいっ
まあ一目瞭然ですよ
あの割り箸を割るっていう行為には
ことを始めるという意味があるんですよ
もなんていうかなそのおもてなしにあたって一期一会の精神でもってね
こうつま先まであの神経を行き渡らせるようなっていうんですかね
そういうもとことん細やかな心遣いがそこにはあったはずなんですよどれがもう一度ま
いいか
を忘れられ
つつあると
そういう状況になっていると僕は思っています
皆さんの音ご自宅であの or んだったりお皿だったり
多くだったりナイフだったりてご家族で共用だったりしませんか
でも箸だけは各人専用だったりしません
まあの食事の音始めから終わりまで聞き手にあるのってお箸
食器だったりその上に乗っている食べものったり
食べればその次のお皿でその上に乗っている食べもまたさらにその次
食べ物に関しては次から次へていきますけど
お箸だけは最初から最後までずーっと同じものを使っているわけですよ
ってね
僕は文のはあの
食事においてもねお箸扇の要なんじゃないのかなって
思うんです
僕の会社ではね
この
ジュースのすぎま鮫利休箸これ一膳一膳
手作業で
共同検査しています
一善一膳手作業でヤスリがけして仕上げています
ご自宅で使われる分にはね10回でも20回でも使えるようなお話なんですよ
まぁちょっと話が飛んじゃうんですけど元々ね
割り箸ってあるたから住宅用の部材を取った後
後の部分生たっていうところがあるんですけどそこから作られました
あの
おなじみのこのもったいない精神というやつですよねそこから作られ始めたのが始まり
なんですよ
で材料は杉が使われていました俺もスギの葉茶ですけどね
です切ってあの実はね日本日本の固有子なんですけど
まあ花粉症の原因でもありますよねもう僕ちょっと今あの席に入れちゃってるんです
けど僕も実は30年代か浮上ででしてもうぼちぼち
あのくるんじゃないのかなっていう感じではあるんですけどね
でその花粉があの多すぎてどうしようもないのはやっぱり
次が多いからなんですよ
ネット大してすぎが多いのかというと林業
スイッ対している方ですよ
今僕の住んでる言い訳なんかはあの
毎年ワースト5に入るぐらい次館
飛んでる
まああの杉丸太の値段て昭和55年ぐらいがピークでもう大体3分の1ぐらい今なっ
ちゃってます
そんだけ値段下がっちゃってると
山の所有施設所有者算定も誰も
誰も金ないそれ儲かんないでね
でもあの岩鬼だったり東北だったりの山っていうのを
やっぱあれできちゃってますよ
どうしようもないと
まあそんな中でですね
あの
ある日ねふと
本屋さんに入ったときに
こんなの見つけたんです田中淳夫さん森林ジャーナリスト田中淳夫さんのね
割り箸はもったいないと思うんですよ
となくうすうす気付いた方いらっしゃる方も思うんですけど今までの話に
第一体受け売り
serene
あっはっは
意外とね8
here の起業しちゃったんですけど
その時にもねだ仲さんねもうリスキーだかでやめておいたほうがいいよ
行ってくれたんですよね
今その他には家族だったり友人だった知人だったり
親身に上がってないんですけど誰かが割り増し
絶対失敗する
もうやめとけパッカリしっ
一貫してあの
賛成してくれしたのは僕の母親だけ1人だけ
あそんな状況ではありました
で割り箸に変にこだわってあの見えるかもしれませんけど
別に僕そんなに割り箸が好きってわけでもないんですよ
死ぬほど好きってわけでもない
でもあの林業を復活させるにはね
間伐をしなきゃいけない間伐をたくさんするには間伐材が売れなきゃいけないわけです
間伐得るために
そのために手段として僕は
高級割り箸の製造っていうのを選んだんですよ
そこで参入したわけでしょ
ありまして環境破壊でもなんでもないんですよ
僕の会社は100%杉の間伐材を使っています
仕入れた生まれたからゴミは一切出ません
割り箸の感想に使う燃料燃料にも石油系の年齢は一切使っていません
本当に悪い事ってなに一つしてないんですよ
ほんとあの外国産のことは
わかんないですけど国産割り箸じゃ勿体なくなんかないんです
一人でも多くの人に
誰かが割り箸っていうイメージからね
されど終わりましていう
イメージ2
あの
代わってもらいたいっ
一人でも考え直していただきたい
日々
これからずっとそう思っています
俺ます